Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
here sir welcome back to our program and
good morning to you I don't know if
he'll be back over the next two years
for the rest of his turn the remainder
of his term or whether or not this is a
one and done operation here
um simple question
what's going to change because of it
nothing in fact it may only get worse
bill because he actually is talking
about bringing more people in you know I
thought it was interesting in in your
clip that mayorkas talked about the
cartels charging six thousand dollars a
person between the entry points I
thought Mallorca said the Border was
Secure apparently he knows the cartels
are pushing people across at 6 000 or
more for Ed so I guess mayorcus really
doesn't know what he's talking about or
he's been lying to us all this time and
when Trump came to the border and I
spent a couple of visits with him down
the border the trick was different Bill
and Dana I mean he came spent a lot of
time I remember in McAllen going right
up to the River's Edge with the
president I remember having a round
table meeting that went for an hour an
hour and a half with with people who
lived on the border with law enforcement
with local officials the president
really wanted to learn Donald Trump
really wanted to learn what was going on
and fix it this President really doesn't
want to know what is going on he didn't
see any illegal immigrants they cleaned
up and sanitized El Paso before he got
there this was just a another store stop
in El Paso like Kamala Harris took
you'll remember that's where she went
away from the action not that a lot of
people haven't been Crossing there but
you know they kind of cleaned up
everything for him sanitized it for his
visit in fact let's just show that we
actually have some pictures call for
number four here for everybody to see at
home this was the situation of migrants
in El Paso photographs of that before
the visit and then after so you can see
that a pretty Stark difference and
usually this can happen when somebody's
coming to town and they don't want him
to see
I do want to ask you about this so now
the the question is no longer when will
you go to the Border because now
President Biden and his team can say he
went to the border so they've answered
that question even if it was kind of a
check the box exercise you have eight
Senators who are going to be going to
the Border uh senator cornyn from Texas
will be one of them do you think that
there might be some way some momentum to
get Texas the resources it needs to
secure the Border as the governor said
in his letter to Biden is 20 billion
dollars in two years too late but is
there some light at the end of the
tunnel here
I don't know uh as long as you have a
Secretary of Homeland Security who's a
liar I don't see much progress he needs
to go he needs to resigner be fired uh
if Biden is serious about uh securing
the Border number one he would offer
Mexico as Congressman Walsh said help to
their military I'm not saying sending
military troops but you know we're
helping Ukraine how about helping Mexico
fight against the cartels who mayorkas
admits is pushing people now he admits
this across the border uh number two I
don't see I don't see any uh reduction
uh we're talking about more people
coming across not less people Biden
should implement the remain in Mexico
policies those seeking Asylum stay in
Mexico it worked very well for president
Trump he should not be fighting uh the
ending of title 42. so he may go there
for a photo op but everything he does is
opposite of what he says and if you
really think about it he didn't say
anything yesterday about securing the
Border we're getting our session
tomorrow and I've already authorized in
our budget which we've been writing for
some time another four billion dollars
in the house has as well that we're
going to spend of Texas taxpayer money
again when Trump was President we spent
about 400 million a year and now we're
spending several billion a year and
that's Texas taxpayer money yeah that
does not that is not fair to the Texas
taxpayers I mean you could not be
spending that money on a lot of other
things and so thank you lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick thank you for your
time I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm aimsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis